for three decades governments around the
world have met every year to forge a
global response to the climate emergency
and a treaty bound under the 1992 united
nations framework convention on climate
change to commit to that
this year it's the 26th iteration of the
un's cop which stands for the conference
of the parties and is seen by many as
our last chance to make a difference to
the future of our planet
the summit is being hosted by the uk and
italy in glasgow and thousands of people
197 parties that's 196 countries plus
the eu
planning to attend
now to get an idea of what agreements
it's hoped will be achieved we need to
look back to cop 21 where there was the
largest gathering of world leaders in
history
and for the first time ever nearly every
country on earth signed the paris
climate agreement now that agreed to
limit global warming to below two
degrees celsius with a hope for one and
a half degrees
to sign the paris agreement though
countries didn't need to tell us how
they would get there but this time they
do
and they have to submit their plans
known as nationally determined
contributions or ndcs
now cop president alok sharma has
challenged some of the world's biggest
emitters china india saudi arabia and
australia to deliver on promises they
made and come up with better climate
targets
and that's because the united nations
has warned the world is facing 2.7
degrees of warming due to some countries
plans simply not going far enough
so now the world turns to cop 26
where the un secretary general says the
era of pledges is over
now is the time to close the emissions
gap and stop a climate catastrophe